right
welcome back everyone so this is lecture
17 of cs229
the topics for today will be uh to
finish uh the expectation maximization
algorithm we'll
prove the convergence of expectation
maximization algorithm
and then we'll apply it uh the
expectation maximum
maximization algorithm to the gaussian
mixture model that we saw last
in the last class and then we'll move on
to a new model
ah called the factor analysis and
solve factor analysis again using
expectation maximization so that's the
plan for today
and before we jump into today's topics a
quick recap of what we saw in the last
class
so in the last class we started off with
unsupervised learning
right and in unsupervised learning we
are given just
data points a set of xs and there is no
supervision that comes along with it
what i mean is there is no y values that
come along with the
corresponding x values we are just given
the x values and we started off with
clustering problems right clustering
problems are those where which we want
to
identify some kind of a hidden structure
where the data kind of clusters into
different groups
the first algorithm that we saw was k
means
in k means we are given a collection of
examples x's and also
let's assume we are also given uh the
number k
of how many clusters we want to identify
and the way we go about
uh executing k means is to
come up is to randomly initialize
k different cluster means where mu j
refers to the jth cluster there are k
such mu js each of those uh cluster
centroids they are called centroids
they live in rd the same space where x
lives in
and then we loop until convergence where
in step one
which you can think of as the e step ah
we set
the cluster identity c i of
the ith element to be the identity of
the jth
cluster centroid to which it is closest
to which its nearest
right so there are k different muse
and for each eye we check which
of the k muse is nearest to it
we where it's commonly we use the l2
distance and depending on which one is
the nearest
we use the argument so the the identity
of the cluster
to which x i is nearest we set that to
be ci
and then what you can think of as the m
step is
for each of the cluster centroids we
only look
at the examples which got assigned to
that centroid in the previous e step
and take the average of those x's to
update our estimate of mu j
right it is this iterative algorithm
where in one step we perform
a cluster center assignment so this is
assignment where we assign
each point to a centroid and then update
the centroids
using the mean of the assigned points
and we also briefly discussed of how
this
overall algorithm can be thought of as
coordinate descent on this loss function
which is also called the distortion
function so the distortion function
takes two parameters the the c's
and the muse the set of all series and
the set of all muse
and this loss function can be minimized
using coordinate descent by coordinate
design what we mean is
we hold some subset of the parameters
fixed
and optimize over the remaining subset
of the parameters and then we hold
the remaining parameters fixed and
optimize over the first
set of parameters and we go on and on
right so
you can think of this step as optimizing
over the c parameters while holding the
muse fixed
and this step as optimizing the mu
parameters while holding the c is fixed
right so that was k means and then we
saw this other model called gaussian
mixture model
so gaussian mixture model we can think
of it as
soft k means
in gaussian mixture model we are again
given k
the number of clusters or the number of
mixtures the gaussian mixtures
that we want to fit we are given the set
of
x's we don't know the cluster identity
if this was supervised learning
then the cluster identities would be the
y i's
and again here if supervised if this was
supervised learning
we would be given the cis which would be
like the y i's
and we assume that the gen the data
generative model
is something like this there is a
so we have a multinomial distribution
which you can think of it as like the
class
prior you know what what's the total
number of examples
in each given cluster that you you can
think of that as a multinomial
and the zi's the cluster centroids are
the cluster identities of every
corresponding x
i's are sampled from this multinomial
right
and then once we know the z i's
each for each identity of z i there is a
corresponding
mu and z right and the x's
are sampled from the corresponding
gaussian
based on the value that z was sampled
from so it's important to note that z in
this case
is discrete right because it is sampled
from a multinomial
we get a z will happen to be one of the
k different
one of the k different gaussian mixtures
and by the choice of z
there is an implicit mu and sigma
associated
with that gaussian and the x
will be sampled from that gaussian right
we think of this as the data generating
distribution
and so the parameters that ah in this
model are the fee
mu and and sigmas in this case the
parameters was
was both the c
c i and the mu i were the or the
parameters so the parameters are in the
green boxes
right and then we came up with this with
this iterative algorithm again
when we came up with this we were just
using heuristics to make it something
that is similar to k-means we had not
yet derived the
e-m algorithm in its in its most general
form
and the algorithm that we came up was
this so set so randomly initialize
the parameters to some values just as in
the case of
k means and then we set wi
for each example right so this loop is
over the number of examples
for each examples we said w i to be
the probability that z i
the probability that z i is the is the
z i equals j given x i
and and the current uh uh current values
of the parameters
and then using these these weights
where the weights is basically telling
us what's the probability that
x i corresponds to the jth
cluster so the sum over j of all these w
i's will be equal to 1
for every i and using these weights
we perform what we call as the m step
which was to
recalculate or update the values of the
parameters
using the current estimates of the
weights right and this again was very
similar to
what we did with k means right so the
the red box think of it as the e step
and the green boxes think of them as the
m step right in the green boxes
we are updating the uh the parameter
based on
what we uh thought of based on what we
what we derived in the e step right in
the in the
in the case of gaussians a mixture of
gaussians each cluster centroid
will be the weighted average of the
excise
in k means it was just the average of
the excise which got assigned to that
cluster
but over here every every example
belongs to every cluster with different
weights so this is just a weighted means
of all the xs
and you know we have corresponding uh
parameter update rules for the fees and
and sigma js
and basically all of these derivations
was very similar to
the case of gda gaussian discriminant
analysis
except you know we have a small few
small ah
changes the changes are that each
cluster centroid can have its own
covariance rather than having a shared
covariance and also that
there are k such uh clusters rather than
just two
right otherwise this is pretty much
exactly the same as
gda and then we moved on to
deriving the the most general form of
the em algorithm
right in the em algorithm what we
wish to maximize is this marginal
likelihood that's
log p of x for a given value of theta
right this is our likelihood objective
had we observed the full data had we
observed all the z's like in the case of
gda we would we would instead maximize
p of x comma z theta
if z was observed
right but ah but z is not observed so
the
the the most rational thing to do is
just to maximize the
ah likelihood given the evidence that we
have right so p of x is also called the
evidence
and we do some base some some
some pretty straightforward algebraic
manipulations
so log p of x is the same as log of
the log of p of x z with z getting
marginalized right that's
by definition log p of x and then
we kind of cook up an expectation out of
out of nothing
by multiplying and dividing it by some
arbitrary
distribution q over z and once we
multiply it and divide it
we can now think of this as an
expectation
right so we had a log and we cooked up
an expectation out of nothing
right and the the to think of
the way we we come from this step to
this step
is described here so the expectation of
some function
g of c where z is ah is distributed
according to q
by definition is the sum over z q of z
times g of z that's just the definition
of expectation
and in this case if we said g of z to be
p
of x z divided by q of z you know this
becomes
the g function right and therefore this
is just the expectation
by just the definition of expectations
right so we started with the log
likelihood that's the that's the one
that we
always want to maximize and the log in
the log likelihood
is a concave function right and then we
cooked up this expectation out of
nothing
by multiplying and dividing it by z so
we got a concave function and an
expectation
using the two we apply jensen's
inequality and density's inequality
allows us to swap the order of the log
and the expectation
by using this inequality right so this
is the
the log likelihood the log in the log
likelihood is the concave function
the expectation is something that we
cooked up out of thin air
and jensen's inequality now allows us to
swap this log and expectation
and get this inequality right and
this inequality we just gave it a name
we call it elbow it's called the
evidence lower bound
because this is the evidence right and
this
is a lower bound of the evidence and the
lower bound was obtained through
jensen's inequality
right and as a corollary we also saw
that jensen's inequality tells us
that this lower bound is exactly equal
to
if and only if q of z that is
uh the the the probability distribution
with which we were
taking uh the expectation happens to be
p of z given x
well jensen's inequality did not tell us
this but we
derived it and showed that as a
consequence q of z
must be equal to p of z given x
in order for this term to be a constant
right now we
we have this jensen's inequality and we
have this corollary and using these two
we then came up with
the the more general form of the em
algorithm
right in the most general form of the m
we assume there is some parameter theta
right in case of gaussian mixture model
theta will be the collection of fees mu
and sigma right we are just calling it
theta
it could be any collection of it could
be any parameter depending on the model
that we have
right and the most general form of the
em algorithm
is again iterative and in each iteration
what we do is
we perform the e step where the e step
is basically calculating
these optimum q distributions
right the optimum q distribution what we
saw here is the is the
posterior distribution of ps p of z
given x
right so in the e step we calculate the
q distributions
right and in the m step we maximize the
elbow
right and the elbow by writing it out in
in you know in a more
verbose form the elbow is basically uh
what what we have over there it is the
sum from
i equals 1 to n across all examples and
this again is just the definition of the
expectation
right q of of z times log of p
of x z theta over q of z
a few things important things to note
here is that
in the e step for each example we
calculate the posterior distribution
right and once we calculate the
posterior distribution
the q's are held fixed during the m step
right that's that's a crucial detail
right the queues over here
are constant we assume these queues to
be constant
even though the qs had thetas in them
we assume that these thetas are from the
previous iteration and we held
we hold them fixed during the m step
right and when we are performing this
arc max over theta
the only theta that is getting optimized
is the theta that shows up over here
right so this is the you know p of x
comma z
divided by by q of z is what we had over
here that went into the elbow
and it is only this theta that we are
optimizing over
in the m step right the q distribution
remember it came from the from the e
step and in the e step in order to
calculate q there was a q
over here but we don't write this as p
of z given x parameterized by theta
because we are not
optimizing that theta we are holding it
fixed
right and we are only optimizing the the
thetas that show up in this
in the in in the in the numerator
right and this gives us a visual
understanding of the em algorithm
where the dotted black line is
log p of x which we assume is
is hot it could be hard to evaluate or
it could be hard to
to optimize directly and we're going to
we're going to we're going to assume
that this is not directly accessible for
optimization
right instead what we do is we start
with some random initialization theta
some theta naught
right and for this particular value of
theta naught
we construct the corresponding q
distribution
as the posterior z given x at that value
of theta naught
right and that gives us the
corresponding elbow
where the q corresponds to uh
q corresponds to the posterior at at a
theta naught
right and this theta naught by
definition
or by the corollary
will be exactly equal to log p of x
over here right so we are at theta
naught
and by constructing the elbow and by
evaluating the elbow
we have effectively evaluate we we know
what value log p
of x is at this at this point
right but now we want to keep improving
our theta values or keep adjusting our
theta values
such that we the the corresponding log p
of x
is increasing right that that's our goal
that our objective is to
find value of theta that maximizes log p
of x
and and we are doing the cm algorithm to
do that indirectly right if we had
observed z
we could have directly performed
gradient ascent or gradient descent over
this
objective however we are doing this
iterative algorithm where in each step
we construct
a lower bound using a specially chosen
value of q
and that value of q is the posterior
distribution of z given x
at theta naught and then
we maximize the elbow instead of
maximizing log p of x
and when when we maximize the elbow
we get an updated value theta one and
this theta one will correspond to
ah the elbow being maximized right
and it is using this theta 1 we now
construct
a new elbow which is tight at
at theta 1 and this elbow has
you know q 1 and q 1
will be the posterior evaluated at theta
right and that is the that is the elbow
of the second iteration
and then we locally and then we maximize
elbow or locally maximize the
elbow of the second iteration to get you
know theta 2
and using this theta 2 we can you know
construct alpha 3 and so on and so on
right so it is this this iterative
algorithm
you know which we call as the e m
and what we are going to do today will
be to give
give a quick and easy proof that proves
that
the em algorithm always converges to a
local optimum
and then we are going to apply it to the
gaussian mixture model and
end up with the same update rules using
this more principled approach of
maximizing
maximizing the elbow iteratively and
then we'll move on to factor analysis
which is a different model
another different latent variable model
where there is a hidden z
and apply em to the factor analysis
model and solve that using em as well so
that's the plan for today any any
questions so far
yes
so the question is what if you have like
uh you're in a if i
if i summarize it correctly what if
you're in a streaming setting where
you're getting new data
um you know and you already have a model
that you fixed with the old data and you
obtained some some more new data if
you're using uh if you're performing uh
market segmentation and you have some
customer data you fit a model
and you got data from new customers
right uh so
the the um now so what you want to do
over there is first
you want to ask the question do we want
to hold on to the same number
you know of clusters k or do we want to
update k
right that's the first question you want
to ask when you get the new data if the
answer
you know if you want to hold on to the
same cluster k then
you can perform em algorithm where you
can use the
the previously optimized parameter
values as the starting
random initialization and then just
refit over the whole data
and you know that hopefully will just
converge faster
however if you uh decide to have you
know a larger k
uh where you want to have more number of
clusters you know with the with the
updated data then
you basically have to just start
randomly effectively
to actually start classifying those
clusters yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so the question is
uh you we fit the new models and and we
get new customer data
and how do we uh place them into um
place them into one of the existing
clusters
in case of k means that would be you
know pretty straightforward
in place of x i you place the new x star
the uh
uh you know the new customer data that
you get and find the minimum the closest
centroid
in case of the gaussian mixture model
you will calculate this posterior
distribution using the bayes rule
to get a a you know a probability
distribution
over your mixtures right and that's
that's
essentially something very similar to
what you did with gda in gda
uh it was only two classes and therefore
it was it took a
a logistic regression form in in case of
a gaussian mixture model
this will end up taking the form of a
softmax right and
because the covariances are different it
will effectively be
soft max using quadratic features
right good question was there another
question yes
em question so is that for each of the i
uh xl so q i will basically put them in
in the z
bins so it's a pdf over like what class
it can belong to so is it like
for a discrete classification yes so the
question is
you know in the e step are we
calculating uh a
discrete distribution over you know the
set of z
set of k classes exactly that's exactly
what happens here for each
x um
so what what you want to do is equals j
equals j right that's what you want
that's how we want to think of this
right
so q is is a multinomial distribution
over the clusters so q in this case will
you know
q of z you know 3 for the third example
once you calculate this will give you a
multinomial distribution over the
k classes so this is cluster 1 through
cluster k and you'll get some value 0.1
0.9
0.01 and so on
so z3 means like the third example
oh so like you know x i you know will
have a z i correspondingly yeah
right was there another question
oh yeah so uh the question is what did i
mean by quadratic features because we
used
covariance we discussed that briefly in
in gda it's it's not super critical that
you understand that
what uh what if you remember in gda what
we uh what we saw was
you know if if your data resides in
two clusters right and we assume they
have equal
covariances then the two covariances
might look like this and the separating
hyper boundary will therefore be a
straight line
right but if we assume different
covariances then it could be
you know a curved line and the posterior
of this
is effectively represented by a
logistic regression that uses quadratic
features of x1 and x2
right so it's it's essentially the same
instead of two you will have
you know k different centroids and
because they're all having different
covariances
right we assume different covariances
for each class that means
it's like you're performing a soft max
with quadratic features
right so logistic the the generalization
of of the logistic function to k classes
the softmax
right and if you assume
[Music]
equal equal covariance of the gaussians
then you will get
effectively get a soft max using linear
features and if you include
different covariances it will
effectively be ah soft max using
quadratic features
but it's not super critical that you
understand the the connection to the uh
softmax and the quadratic features yes
questions
[Music]
exactly so so uh the the fact that
uh so the question is um the elbow
touches lock p of x over here e
does it touch because you know we
intentionally carefully constructed the
elbow to be that way and that's exactly
right
we construct the elbow over here such
that the q
in the elbow is the posterior that makes
it tight at log p of x
right so let us move on ah so
so the proof of of y
e m algorithm converges
proof of e m
convergence right
so so the proof of em convergence is
something that we have
almost seen ah over here right so in
order to prove that ah
e m our strategy will be to show
that for
every t or time step or every iteration
l
theta of t plus 1
is greater than or equal to l theta
of t so l
over here is our objective that we want
to
uh optimize so
l theta is that is log
p of x theta
and what we want to show is by by
performing the em algorithm
by iteration after iteration the
log likelihood of ah of of uh the
marginal log likelihood of p of x
is always increasing with each iteration
of em algorithm that's what we want to
show
right and by showing this and also by
recognizing the fact
that the log likelihood is is bounded
above so log likelihood cannot go up to
you know infinity
using those two uh assumptions we will
we will make the case that because l is
bounded above
and because with every iteration we are
increasing
the value of l eventually we will
converge and
so what remains is to is to show this
this condition and to show this
condition we will basically use the same
reasoning that we saw
with the diagrams over here
right so um
l theta t plus one
right is greater than or equal to
elbow of x
q t
theta t plus one
why is this the case so l theta
this is uh this is basically just the
uh definition of
of what jensen's inequality gave gave us
that
the log likelihood for
for the same values of theta the the
likelihood p of x will always be greater
than or equal to
the elbow for any values of of q
right
and this is
greater than or equal to
elbow of x
q t and theta t
right so this was
jensen's inequality
why is this the case
exactly this this is because because of
the m step right
so the m step guarantees that um
that theta t plus 1 was chosen to be the
maximizer
of of this so so theta t plus 1 over
here will give us the
the highest value for for elbow and
therefore this is due to m step
because we had the ah theta t plus one
was chosen to be the r
max of the of ah of this ok
and then um
and this is equal to
l theta of t
and why is this the case
right this is the corollary of jensen's
inequality
right so what is this basically telling
us so to kind of visualize
uh to visually understand this proof l
theta of t
plus 1 so this black dot over here
right this is l theta of 1 right assume
t
equals 0 right l theta of 1
it says is greater than equal to the
elbow
right it's always greater than the elbow
so the elbow evaluates
to a point here right
right this is greater than zero is step
one
right and step two basically told us
elbow evaluated at theta t plus one is
greater than elbow evaluated at theta t
so that tells us that
this is greater than 0 that step 2 of
the inequality
right because theta theta 1 was chosen
to
maximize the blue curve
right and then step three tells us that
that l theta equals the elbow
and and that's because we we constructed
we intentionally constructed the blue
elbow
to be equal to log p of of
x at uh at the current value at
theta t right so that basically tells us
the gap between
the the the gap between the the
the the blue line and the black line at
this is
is basically zero right so that tells us
that
l of theta zero is less than l of
theta one right it it so so at each step
we are guaranteed not to
get worse in terms of the log likelihood
next question
so once we so so um so the question is
should this be q t minus one
so i'm saying
minus one comma theta so l theta of t
will be equal to elbow where q is
evaluated at the posterior of theta
right yes so that is that is theta t so
the right hand side is in the m
right so this is the e step we get this
from the e step
yep
so the next step yeah so so e step so
at the current value of theta we use the
e step to calculate
q of t and using q of t we construct the
elbow and that elbow will be equal
right and then from this elbow so this
is basically like starting at theta
naught
in the picture and constructing the blue
elbow
right so the blue elbow will be equal to
this and
the the next step is to go from theta t
to theta t plus 1 by optimizing the blue
elbow
so l theta of t is has no q right l
theta of t is just l theta of the l
theta of t is just
not p of x there is no q in it
right is it is this clear any questions
cool so it's so so the proof here
turns out to be pretty intuitive uh you
know it it it can be easily visualized
what we are saying is we start at any
value of ah of theta
some random value of theta right the
log likelihood has you know evaluates to
some value which
we may or may not be able to calculate
right but we can always construct an
elbow
such that log p of x equals to that
elbow at that point
right so we construct the elbow it is
guaranteed to be lower than
then ah log p of x and then we optimize
the elbow right so once we optimize the
elbow we reach a higher point at the
elbow
now it is important that this point over
here was tight
what would happen if this point was not
tight
what would happen if the elbow was not
tight over here
right so what would happen if um if
if this was not guaranteed to be tight
is that
it may well have been the case
that the likelihood function goes like
this
and if this was not tight we may have
gone down in our likelihood rather than
guaranteed to be going up right
because this was tight at at q naught
because it was tight we you know the the
other two pieces of the proof
allow us to connect l theta of ah
l of theta 1 to be greater than l of
theta of zero
if this were not to be tight then the
likelihood at theta naught could have
been
much higher and we may have actually
gone worse
in terms of our optimizing our objective
is that clear cool
all right so now we have derived the the
most general form of
the e m algorithm here uh
z's and x's could be anything and
the joint probability of the model we
made no assumption of
the joint probability of p of x and z to
take any specific form
right and now we will taking this
you know more generic algorithm we will
see how we can
apply it to the gaussian mixture model
and and
basically see that we will end up with
the same update rules
so this part will be super quick ah
i'll just give some some some hints on
how to go about it and in your homework
you'll be
basically doing a more detailed version
of ah what will be doing now
so to derive ah
so g gaussian mixture model
via e m
right so for the gaussian mixture model
via em
first we do the e step
right so in the e step
for each eye
right so before we we um before we go
into uh how we go about doing it
uh a general kind of uh template or you
know thumbs up rules to follow when you
want to apply em
is to first always uh get clarity on
what the model is
right first step one
right write out
p of x comma z
and what i mean by write out is write
out your assumptions right
you may observe only x's and z's that is
fine we may only observe x's and not z's
independent of what your what data you
observe and what you don't observe
first write out your model and by
writing out your model
it may be something like this you know z
comes from
multinomial right and then
x given z comes from normal
ah of mu z and
sigma z why do we call this the model
because
this is effectively p of z
times p of x given z and this
is equal to p of x comma z
right so first write out your model and
writing it in this form is is basically
called as writing the data generative
process
and writing the data generative process
you're implicitly defining what the
model is
right so the first thing you want to
always do is write out the model
and be clear what the data generating
process is and what your parameters are
right and in this case the parameters
basically ah
are p of x comma z the parameters
will be phi mus and
sigma right be clear on what the
parameters are
and what the what's the form of the full
model
and then the step two
is clearly identify what are latent
and what are
observed are
you know what's the evidence
and and and in most of the models that
we will see
x will generally be the evidence
that is the part of the data that is
observed
and z will be latent
that's how we generally name the things
so when you when you when you look at
the models
in the nodes or in general you know x
will generally refer to something that
is observed
that will be given to us and z will
generally refer to
you know some latent variable that is
not observed
right and ah
and then once once you are clear
about what the full model is what the
parameters are
what is observed and what is latent only
then
attempt to apply em on it right
if you you're not clear of of you know
what what you know if you're not clear
about these first two steps
it's going to be very hard to apply em
and you're gonna just get confused
really badly
right always be clear on what the full
model is
the data generating process which is the
same as the model what the parameters
are
what's observed and what's latent right
in case of the gaussian mixture model
the
the z's the latent variables are the
cluster identities
right the parameters are the
uh uh the uh the multinomial parameters
the
the different sets of mu and sigmas
right those are the parameters in
gaussian mixture model
and what's observed are just the x's
without the cluster identity
right there is also a difference between
um
another thing to be clear about is there
are two kinds of unknowns here
right so we have the unknown latent
variables and the unknown parameters
what's the difference between the two
right the unknown latent variables
are example specific right for a
different
choice of x you will have a different
latent variable
whereas the unknown parameters are
global
they are not specific to any example the
means and the covariances and the
and the parameters of the multinomial
they are kind of global in the sense
that they don't belong to any specific
example
whereas the latent variables are paired
with a given example
right and ah and and this kind of a
model you can think of it as a
frequentist model where we
we consider the parameters to be unknown
constants
whereas but you can also perform a
bayesian treatment of this where you
consider
everything to be a random variable but
you know that's beyond the scope
for the em algorithm it is it is clear
that
it's important that you're clear what
the what the parameters are
and the parameters are global they are
not specific to any example
and there's this other kind of unknown
which is the latent variable
which is paired with an example
and what we do in the e step is
basically
estimate this latent variable that is
pair with each example
right which is why in the e step we loop
over each eye
you are calculating what the
corresponding hidden latent variable is
for this for the given example by
holding the parameters fixed
right and in the m step we go the other
way we assume we
you know you know the z values are you
know the z values
what they are and then we go about
updating the parameters in the m step
right so in the e stem we are we are
kind of attacking
one kind of unobserved which is specific
to each example and in the m step we are
attacking the other kind of unknown
which is global
and this is going to be common in all
kinds of
models where you are applying em right
in the e-step we are attacking the
latent variable in the m step we are
attaching the parameters
right so
so the e step in gaussian mixture model
will is basically
for each i right for each i
q i of
z i equals j
is equal to
[Music]
p of z i given
x i at the current values of
phi mu sigma
now how do we write how do we obtain the
posterior distribution of z unit x
using bayes rule exactly and this
is p of
x given z times p of z
over p of x
right and again this because z is
discrete this will be p
of x given z times p of z
over summation over all z
p of x given z times
p of z right and this turns out to be p
of x given z what is p of x given z here
p of x given z is a is normal
distribution
right and
and p of x given z will therefore be ah
one over
[Music]
square root 2 pi
to the
2 pi to the d by 2.
this is just i'm just writing out the uh
the
multivariate gaussian you know sigma
j to the 1 by 2 that's the law the
determinant
times
the exponent we have
x i minus mu j
transpose sigma j inverse
and in times
times p of z
p of z is just v
because it's you know v j and and uh
because it's it's uh you know everywhere
it's implicit that
we are trying to do is equal to j
so this is just v j now here sum overall
j
you know the same thing
this question
should there be yeah here there is a
minus half yeah thank you minus 1
over 2 right so
we've done such calculations before
right we've
calculated such posteriors in gda and we
also saw that
if the if p of x given c belongs to the
exponential family there's going to be
an exponent here
right and then there are all these
constants they can get absorbed into the
exponent you can take the log of this
take it in
and you get you know exponent of
something divided by exponent of
something plus exponent of something
plus exponent of something that
works out to be the soft max comes out
to be in the soft max form
right and yeah so this is basically you
know
you know all the values here plug it in
and you get
you get the estimates for for for the
e-step
so that's the e-step and
[Music]
i'm going to erase this hopefully you
have taken note of
this right and in the m step
now in m step m step what we want to do
is mu
sigma phi is equal to
arg max of mu sigma
phi right
and in the m step we do the arc max over
the at the elbow exactly
and the elbow can be written as
what we saw over here so
the uh elbow we have written out the the
uh expanded version there
and for simplicity let's just call this
w
i j we call it w i j because once we
calculate it
this will be held constant in the m step
right
even though w i j depended on the values
of theta
of the parameters to get calculated
in the m step we will not be optimizing
over them we're going to
hold them fixed right and because that's
that's for the the the
the elbow should be held fixed and ah
we are going to arc max over the elbow
expression here
and that will be sum over i equals 1 to
n
sum over z
w i j
or here we can write j equals 1 to k
w i j off
so the elbow is
so the elbow is basically the
expectation of the log of
this term right it will be log
p of x i
z i given theta
mu
sigma and phi
divided by w
i j
right this is just writing out the elbow
by expanding out the expectations
right and this
arc max mu sigma
phi i equals one to n
[Music]
j equals 1 to k w
i j now this we can
again break down the joint according to
our data generating process
so this will be p of
x given z
or c i equals k or z i equals j
times p of z i equals j
over w i j
now again the same process that we did
over here p
of x given z will be a multivariate
gaussian pdf
p of z given j is is the multinomial
which will be just phi of j
right and w the two w's are constants
for this for the m step the two w's are
constant
in the e step we derive them using the
previous values of theta
or the previous values of the parameters
but once we calculate them in the e step
we will hold we will hold them frozen in
the m step for performing the
maximization
right so plug in the values of of the
gaussian pdf here
plug in vj here and to perform arc max
how do we perform arg max
take the gradient set it equal to zero
solve for the parameters
right it just looks pretty you know big
and nasty but
you know it's pretty straightforward
there's no there's no
special tricks going on here it's just
tedious right so write out the uh
uh write out the uh gaussian pdf here
vj here take the derivatives set it
equal to 0
and once you do that for separately for
fee mu and j
you will end up getting phi is equal to
um
1 over n i equals 1 to n
w i j
and mu hat will be
basically the same thing
so basically this will be mu hat and
sigma hat
will be you know
this thing right so write it out like
this
take the gradient set it equal to 0 and
we get this
right and this is the way we start from
the general
em algorithm you know work out the e
step and
m step and in the m step work out the
maximization
and by following this principled
approach we will see that we will end up
with the same
update rules that we get by for you know
that we obtain using the
heuristic soft k-means kind of an
argument next question
exactly so the question is do we have k
different mu and k different sigmas yes
so over here
when i write mu i mean the collection of
k different new vectors
and k different you know covariance
matrices
yeah so in the m step we simultaneously
update all of those
exactly yeah you can do it for any mu j
or sigma j and you know
it's symmetric so once you do it for one
it's the same procedure for
doing ah updating all the others good
question
so that's that's ah em
and em applied to ah gaussian mixture
models
so what we did basically was to was to
come up with a general em algorithm
and using the general em algorithm first
uh in order to apply to gaussian mixture
model the first thing we had to do was
get clarity on what the model was
what's the full joint probability
distribution of of
all the of all the variables x's and z's
have clarity on what the model
parameters are
in case of gaussian mixture model it was
fee collection of muse collection of
covariance matrices sigmas
right and then get clarity on what's
observed and what's not observed
once you know what's observed and what's
not observed it becomes clear what you
need to do in the e-step in the e-step
we need to calculate the posterior the
probability of unobserved
given the observed whatever it is for
your specific model
construct the construct the e step
of probability of unobserved given the
observed
and we hold the parameters fixed right
and
the the steps of evaluating this will be
different for different models for
gaussian mixture models
this happened to be normal and
multinomial for a different model in
factor analysis that we are going to see
next
these might be different right but the
but the general recipe is the same
construct the construct the posterior
distribution or the
in the e step and then in the m step
write out the elbow
right write out the elbow by plugging in
the
full model in the numerator and uh
and the uh the the prosthetic the q
distributions in the
in the denominator and in the
expectation the denominator
and the the probability with which we're
taking the expectation are constant
in the m step right we are going to
hold them constant and by holding them
constant
we are going to optimize over these set
of parameters
right when we do the arg max it is only
these parameters that we are updating
there are you know kind of hidden
parameters inside these
that were used in the in the e step but
we are not going to optimize them
for for the purpose of the m step the q
distributions
are fixed right we're going to only
optimize over these
and when we take the gradient everything
except these will be assumed to be
constant
right and basically you know this is
just calculus you know
take the gradient set them equal to 0
and we end up with
the update rules that is specific to
your model and what was absurd and what
is not observed
okay any questions
yes
because let's say for the eighth example
if it is associated with the jth cluster
why
so the question is why are we summing
over j because in only in k means we do
we assign it to only one point in in in
in case of the gaussian mixture model
we we every point belong to every
cluster with different weights
so this what we got here was purely a
consequence of applying the em algorithm
and the em algorithm we
we proved that it will you know converge
and it will maximize
so the choice of summing over here was
not an arbitrary choice it's just a
consequence of the em algorithm
yes questions
so the question is instead of taking the
expectation uh
what if instead we took the mode and you
know take the the highest
highest probability in that case we will
gaussian mixture models will
will will be kind of modified into
becoming k-means
in that case all right
so factor analysis
so factor analysis probably has
the most tedious
calculus in all this course so
there's going to be quite a lot of
symbols that are going to
come up on the board but
even though the the uh the expressions
might look complex
and hard the idea is pretty simple
fact analysis
so in fact analysis we
consider an interesting and challenging
scenario
so in fact analysis right you have x i
belonging to some r d
right and you are given a collection
x i y equals 1 to n
and now we are interested in this
in this kind of ah situation where
d is much bigger than n
right in most of the most of the common
scenarios that we encounter
the number of examples that we that we
have will generally be
be much bigger than the dimension of the
data
but there can be situations where the
dimension of the data is much bigger
than the number of examples that we have
right and it is it is challenging
because
when we ah using this if we if we
assume this came from some kind of a
gaussian distribution and if we estimate
the covariance matrix sigma
sigma will now be one over n
sum over i equals one to n
x i minus mu
x i minus mu transpose
right so each of this each each term
inside the sum is
is one rank one matrix and you're
summing over
n rank one matrices so sigma will be
rank n but
n is much smaller than d right sigma is
a d
by d matrix but it is only rank n right
and now if you want to
use this covariance matrix to to
calculate your gaussian pdf
right a gaussian pdf is p of x given
mu sigma one over
two pi to the d by two
so the determinant over here will be 0
because
it is it is it's not full rank right and
and because you get you get a
zero in the denominator you know you
can't even evaluate the the uh
evaluate the pdf right and and uh
the question is now what do we do in
such scenarios yes what's that question
i'm sorry this will be rank n because we
are summing over
n rank 1 matrices
matrix is d by d sigma is
d by d right but it will have only rank
n and most of the times when n is bigger
than d
it will be rank d
right but in in cases where n is much
smaller than d
ah you know the rank will be so so this
will be a singular matrix
and you know we can't do much with it
yes question
uh i i wouldn't say so i'll come to that
so we we are now just considering a
scenario where x's are coming from
a high dimensional space and um
and the number of dimensions is much
greater than
the number of the number of dimension is
much greater than the number of examples
we have
right we can think of kind of
you know a few ways in which we can kind
of
address this so one way is you know
instead of thinking
instead of considering sigma to be you
know a full-blown covariance matrix
maybe we can restrict sigma to be just
the diagonal matrix
so that the number of parameters reduce
but even if you
limit it to a diagonal matrix the
number of of diagonal values is still d
that is greater than n
we could also think of sigma
thinking of restricting sigma to be some
kind of a scalar times the identity
matrix
but if we do this then we are
effectively limiting ourselves to
covariances that are spherical right and
that may not capture all the interesting
structure in your data so this wouldn't
be very interesting either
so instead what we want to now
now do in in with factor analysis
is to think of a latent variable z
so assume that your data the true data
that ah so so we are observing xs but we
are going to assume that these x's
live on some kind of a lower dimensional
subspace
right so we are going to assume that
there is a z
i that is normally distributed
right and then we are going to make this
second assumption
that right so over here i
is
i is basically k dimensional
and z i is therefore
rk so we are going to assume that there
is this lower k dimensional subspace
in which these reside right
and from these from this k dimensional
subspace
we are now
so x given z
is now a normal distribution with mean
mu plus so in the in
in the notes they use
capital lambda right to to denote the
um the up mapping matrix
i personally don't like greek letters
there's nothing against greeks but
i'm just going to call it l because you
know
it looks less scary right so there is a
matrix l times z
and a covariance
psi right let's leave one greek one more
greek in there no problem
right so here l is
a matrix that maps us from k
to d d by k
right and you can assume
psi is
are there any greeks here what's the
right way to pronounce this
is it c or psi anybody knows
psi psi all right so we'll call it psi
so psi is
d by d and we're going to assume it is
diagonal
all right so what is happening here you
can assume that
there is this low dimensional
or k dimensional subspace where k
we will assume is less than n the number
of examples that we have
right and there are these latent
variables
z's that reside in this k dimensional
subspace
which get mapped on to a higher
dimensional
space which is excess and the way it
gets
it gets mapped on is through this you
know
what what you can call as you know an
uplifting matrix
where uh z's when you multiply it with l
it takes you from k dimensional to so l
z will be in d dimensions
and there is uh you know it gets shifted
by
some some offset mu and some there is
some random ah
noise that is that gets a diagonal noise
that that gets added
right so previously in gaussian mixture
models
you know to compare it to gaussian
mixture models these were multinomial in
gaussian mixture models but now z is
continuous here
right x given z was
in the gaussian mixture model was
normally distributed
here also it is normally distributed
except
in the gaussian mixture model for each z
because z was discrete
we had a separate mu and a sigma
but over here we are not going to have a
separate mu and a sigma
but the the the mean for x given z
will be this term which is some
parameter mu
that's common across all examples plus
the mapping of z from the load from the
k dimensional lower
subspace to d dimensional that's the
higher dimensional subspace so l
is this mapping that takes you from a
low dimension to a high dimension
this question
is you're not doing discrete
classification
so this so in fact analysis we have
moved on from classification
and here we are essentially trying to
find a subspace of our
of our of of the x's that we have right
x's live in a high dimensional subspace
what we are trying to do is to find a
low dimensional subspace
in which they reside
and the corresponding and we assume that
the
the x's that we observe have a
corresponding
latent variable z
and the way x is generated from its
latent variable is through this relation
the goal here is to fit as with all
unsu you know probabilistic unsupervised
models the goal is to
p of x you know theta in this case theta
is
you know mu sigma and and
yeah mu
so what do we have here mu psi
and l right and we want to find
this mu sine l such that we have we have
a probabilistic model or a density
estimator over xs
and it would you know there are many
interesting um
uh scenarios where this this uh this can
happen for example
um you you can you know um
the reasons the the kind of scenarios
where this can be useful is supposing
you have
some kind of a temperature sensor right
so you can have temperature sensors that
are
you know spread across your building
right and let's say there are
d such sensors right and if you measure
all your sensors at a particular time
that collection of observations can be
your x i's right so
x i belongs to rd
so instead of i you can think think of
it as t at one time you measure
you take the you know measurement of all
your sensors temperature sensors in your
entire building
and you get a d dimensional high
dimensional uh subspace
but you know all these these are
different uh temperature
uh values may not be independent which
means
you know two temperature sensors inside
this room are probably going to give you
you know very similar values right and
ah
similarly if you have 10 different
sensors here's maybe the you know you
might
see some slight changes where you know
it might be closer to where the
the light bulbs are because of you know
it's warmer and maybe colder in a few
places but
more or less you know they're not
independent and there are these
um these you know similarly if you
you know collect the set of all
temperature sensors in the entire
building
there are probably a few factors that
that affect the different sensor
readings across all the you know across
all the sensors
right and basically what we are trying
to find out ah
what we are our goal here is to come up
uh with a model you know for p of x
and and and and for example ah come up
with a model for p of x
to get a sense of what are normal sensor
readings
right and using this you can probably
build some kind of an anomaly detector
to see if there is you know a fire going
on somewhere
right and the the idea here is that
even though x's reside in a much higher
dimensional subspace
their values the actual temperatures
that they end up measuring are based on
a few much
fewer factors right and
these are you know that live in a k
dimensional subspace the assumption here
is that there are probably just
k factors that decide the temperatures
that you observe in all the d
sensors and and and you know given these
these d dimensional observations we are
trying to build a model from which
we can not only fit p of x well
but also hopefully make inference about
z given x
right so its kind of dual purpose uh in
in case of gm gaussian mixture models
these were discrete
you know where we were trying to cluster
data but here it's it's
it's a fundamentally different problem
where we are trying to find subspaces in
our data
we will do em on this right em made no
assumption about z being discrete or
or or um discrete or continuous
in in uh when we wrote out the
the elbow right so we intentionally used
expectation here and if z
was continuous then this summation will
be an integral
right we make no assumptions about z
being continuous or discrete in em right
so ah so back to where we were so p of x
uh we want to we want to learn a model p
of x
so that we can do things like anomaly
detection
this question
yeah so the question is is is k going to
be learned automatically or is it going
to be hyper parameter
for the purposes of this lecture assume
it's a hyper parameter
and you tune different values of k
yes question is z defined this way just
to map
it from a higher dimension space or is
there any other reason
yeah so so this is this is uh the uh the
assumptions that we are making over here
are what is called as
you know factor analysis
right and there are there are uh you
know few variants of factor analysis
in fact so here we are assuming you know
the the
uh the psi matrix is diagonal and has
you know different values on the
diagonal you can tweak you know that
assumption to say there is you know
equal
there is there is uh equal noise in
along all the diagonals
um and and you know that gives you a
different model
uh you can make few other you know small
little changes here and that gives you
something called as
probabilistic pca this specific set of
assumptions is called factor analysis
yeah so that's just uh you know an
assumption that we are making
yeah that's so the assumption that z has
mean zero and identity one is just
an arbitrary assumption and it turns out
to be that you know it
it is most of the times that's that's
good enough
right so the making an assumption that
our x's has mean
zero and identity one would be you know
observed
right but then we have this you know
offset mu
and you know uh scaling l that we
applied to z
so you know uh it usually that that you
know this this
um the the l and mu make up for the fact
that we don't have any
degrees of freedom here
right so
and now our goal is to using using
this set of assumptions we want to
maximize
we want to learn log p of x
given mu l and psi
right how do we go about doing it
the answer is em right
and as i uh mentioned already
the the first thing to do in em
is to be clear on what the model
right
so the model that we have was described
like this initially
so z comes from normal
zero identity and
x given z comes from normal
mu plus
l z and psi
we are now going to make this small
change and
rewrite this as an equivalent model
z
identity epsilon
comes from zero
psi and x is equal to
mu plus l
z plus epsilon
now with this modification white will
still not
like our initial problem was that sigma
was non-invertible because it was sparse
why we'll see why spiral
psi will not be passed we're going to
work it out right so
right so these two are basically
equivalent
are there any questions on why these two
are equivalent or not
right because we we will we will be
using this trick again
in in a couple of lectures are you clear
on why these two are equivalent
so this is basically called the the
scale and location property of
gaussians where if you take you know
some gaussian right and
so this basically follows from the fact
that um over here
um you can write x as
uh you can decompose this into into two
parts
so you can uh
x given c has this mu plus l z
and and sigma
so this basically uh tells you that for
this given
mean so think of this as the mean
and think of this as the covariance
right
so a normal distribution if it has some
mean and some
covariance you can write this as
m plus normal distribution with some
mean
and some covariance
right
right so yeah so this is bad notation
think of them as you're adding
one one number to a random variable
that's distributed according to that
so so assume uh you know there is a
random
random variable which has mean m and uh
which which is disputed normally
according to mean m and stand you know
covariance s right this random variable
can be written as
the sum of a constant plus another
random variable
right so this uh this other random
variable has mean zero and and
standardized right
so we're basically you know doing
essentially the same so here the
this is epsilon over here
this question
so you know for so x had you know mean
you know i mean you can see here right
so this is just mu plus lz
and we just imagine x u plus lc plus
epsilon
it will but this is just x equals you
know we haven't written the distribution
of x here
right you can just rewrite x as as this
thing
right so um so this gives us
you know using making this observation
we can now write out
model you know of z comma x
will have some
joint mu
z x and some covariance sigma
right so what we are going to do for the
next few minutes is to
write out this model right and once we
are clear about the model and clear
about the different components then we
are going to attack it using em so first
as as we did it with the gaussian
mixture model first we want to be very
clear about the model
what are the latent variables what are
the observed variables what are our
parameters
right and it turns out that
we can
so this mu z x
will have two parts a mean corresponding
to z and a mean corresponding to x
right this is just the standard
multivariate gaussian properties we
we saw such we saw these properties
using
when we were talking about gaussian
processes right so
this will correspond to the mean of z so
the mean of z is just
0 right and the mean of
x
so the mean of x will be just
so what will be the mean of x
mean of x is equal to the mean of
mu plus l z plus epsilon
this is equal to mu plus zero plus zero
just mu mu
so for the for the joint probability
distribution p of x comma z
is distributed according to a normal
distribution whose mean
is you know zero mu right
and the covariance
so again the covariance will have four
parts right so
here we will have covariance of
z covariance of
[Applause]
variance of x x z
x z transpose and covariance of
x right and
it can be shown pretty straightforwardly
that covariance of z
is just identity right
and this will the covariance of
of
the covariance of or this
this is so the covariance of
x and e covariance of
x and z is basically by definition
expectation
of x minus expectation of
x z minus
expectation of z transpose
and if you expand this out this will
just turn out to be
l
here you get l transpose and so this
will be l transpose
this will be l and here you get l
l transpose plus psi
right so the the the model or the or the
joint probability of x and z
is going to be a normal distribution a
multivariate gaussian distribution
whose mean is given by
uh you know 0 and mu and whose
covariance
is given by identity
l l transpose l l transpose plus upside
and the way you arrive at these is by
basically going with the
definition of covariance of x and z to
be expectation of x minus expectation of
x
times z minus expectation of z transpose
right
and and ah similarly for the expectation
of x
uh you do the same x minus expectation
of x x minus expectation
transpose and you will get these terms
and you know the detail steps are in the
notes
but the ah but the the the uh the higher
level message that we want to take ah
take from this is given some
some data generating process the first
step that we did
was to come up with the definition of
the model
so the model in this case
turned out to be x and z
are jointly
multivariate gaussian with a given
you know with some particular mean and
some particular
covariance right
so the model
right that was our the first step that
we want to do
is p of x comma z
is such that x z
is jointly normal with mean
0 mu
or z x rather
z x mu and
covariance i
l transpose l
and l l transpose plus psi
right so this is the you know the full
model
and the parameters
parameters are basically mu
l and psi
right and in this what have you what do
we observe
what is observed in this x and the
latent variable
is z right so
parameters evidence latent variable
right and now
to apply e m on this
in the e step
you want to calculate p of z given x
right so in the e step
we attack the latent variables and in
the m step
we want to do mu l sigma
equals r max
of the elbow
right so this is this is going to be the
the high level flow of what we are going
to do next
right and this this this recipe is the
same
for any kind of model on which any kind
of latent variable model that we want to
solve using em
right first get clarity on the full
model of the joint distribution
identify what are the parameters what's
the evidence what's the latent variable
and then figure out the e step and the m
step where in the e step
can you know uh re-estimate the latent
variables
and in the m step re-estimate the
parameters
right
it so happens that in this
in the in the in the factor analysis
model
it so happens that because they are
jointly
gaussian you know this is you know a
side note
right we we can actually write
l of mu sigma
oops not sigma right sigma there no
mu l and psi
log p of x
you know using those parameters and
using the marginalization property
of of gaussians this actually has
you know you can you can write it out as
um
you know x is actually distributed
according to normal
you know ah we can just read of this it
has normal mu
and variance l l transpose sigma right
mu l transpose plus
sigma right
but now if you try to
ah perform maximum likelihood estimation
and
obtain expressions for these you cannot
get a close form expression
right which is why ah em kind of comes
and comes to our help here
because uh in in this case it so happens
that log p of x
you can actually write out you know it
as one over
you know two pi to the d by two
and here l l transpose plus
psi to the half exponent
minus one half x minus mu
transpose l l transpose plus
psi inverse x minus mu
right you can write it out like this
but there is no closed form solution
that you can that you can
come up with for l's and l's and uh psi
you can try it out but you know you this
cannot be solved
ah using closed form so instead what we
do is
we use factor analysis sorry
expectation maximization and with
expectation maximization
we actually do get closed form
update steps for both the e-step and
m-step though they are
a bit tedious in terms of
how complex the expressions look but
it is you know pretty straightforward
it's just tedious it's not tricky
right so for e m for factor analysis
the first thing we want to ah you know
attack for the e step is
calculate
p of z given x
right p of z given x
in this case both z and x are are
jointly
gaussian you know which is the best you
can hope for right when
ah i'm going to just write out the the
full model here
so z
z x
normal zero mu
and covariance plus identity
l transpose l
ll transpose plus psi
right so what is p of z given x
you know looking at this we can just
read it off right if you if you ah
we did the same thing for in in gaussian
processes where
we calculated the the conditionals of
gaussians
right in this case um
in this case p of z given x will be
z given x will have a normal
distribution
where the mean is given by
l transpose
l l transpose plus psi
inverse
x minus mu right so this is basically
you know if you if you remember a
b if they are jointly distributed
as you know mu
[Music]
mu a mu b
and some kind of a covariance sigma
a square rho sigma a
sigma b rho sigma
a sigma b and rho sigma b
square now uh
a given b will be normal
this basically you know i'm just i'm
just recapping what we have seen
in the past a given b will be mu b
or b minus mu b divided by
sigma b you know get like the the obtain
the
the z value of of b times
rho times sigma a
that'll be the mean and the covariance
is is like the
sure complement right so it was
sigma a square minus
in this case uh so this minus
this times the inverse times this so
it was rho
square sigma a square
right in case of a and b and this is
basically
ah being done in the in the multivariate
case
so it's basically the same thing but
with with matrices instead of scalars
right and this will give us the
sure complement that so that is
covariance will be i
minus
l transpose inverse of this ll transpose
plus psi inverse times
l
right so this is the
shared component
right and this is is is like
calculate the the uh um z value so x
minus
mu divided by the uh the the
covariance times um l transpose which is
basically
map it back to the the variance of of c
right so this is z given x any questions
on this
and now once we have
z given x we basically are able to
calculate
set q i of z i
to be normal with this mean
and this variance right so that gives us
our e step in the e step
we're going to we're going to hold the
current estimates of the parameters
fixed
and calculate the posterior of z given x
right in the m step
so in the m step we want to do
hard max of mu l
psi of the elbow
right so sum over i equals 1 to n
and now we will have an integral of
over z i in place of the summation over
k
different clusters we instead have an
integral over
over the z space
of log p of
x i z i
parameterized by mu l psi
divided by
ah i missed q
i of z i divided by
q i of c
i
mu l psi
equals this right so this is the m step
now there are a few observations we can
make here so the first thing
is that we are going to first
think write it out as an expectation
right so the expectation makes it
makes it easier to understand so this is
arc max mu l psi
i equals one to n expectation
where z i
comes from q i
off
so we're going to factor this into x
given z times p
of z and in the denominator we have q
and there's a log so this will be log p
of x given z
plus log of z minus log of q i
right so factor this into two and these
three apply to log so you get log a plus
log b minus log c
right so this will be addition of
log p of x i
given z i
plus log p of
z i minus
log q i
of c i
right so this is the m step
any questions on this yes question
yes so this integral and q i became the
expectation
good question right so one thing that we
can observe
here is that in all
in any kind of an em
whenever you apply em this part over
here
was is lot p of z so this was the
numerator and this was the
denominator right so this is the
denominator
that's log q is log q and this is the
numerator
right in numerator we factored out into
two parts right
in all whenever you apply em no matter
what the model is
you always have this denominator q
that does not have any of the parameters
that you want to optimize right so the
parameters that you want to optimize
are always in the numerator
right and there is a log so which means
in any given em model
when we are performing arg max we can
just
strike out this part
not just in factor analysis or in
gaussian mixture model
whenever you apply em right in the elbow
the denominator because there is a log
log log of this this ratio the log of
the denominator
will never have the parameters that we
are optimizing over so you can always
just strike out the the log q
over here specifically in the case of
factor analysis
we make yet another observation that
log p of z also has no parameters
because we assumed
z comes from from a normal distribution
of zero i
right that also had no parameters right
so in case of
of factor analysis we gain this
additional cancellation of this p of z
as well
right so now all we are left with is so
x given z
has
so what was x given z x given
z had a normal of yeah so this does have
the
the uh you know this does have mu
l and psi it has all three of them right
it's parameterized by mu l
and z and so we are we basically need to
perform
arc max of of this term with respect to
new l and c this question
ah we have not yet we have not yet and
i'm not sure if we will have the time to
come to there yet but let's wrap up as
much as we can
so and now once once we have written out
in this form
it is basically just calculus right ah
it's it's going to be ah so log p of x
given z
can be can be written out as
this can be written out as
r max of mu l
mu l psi
i equals one to n expectation of
z i from q i
of log one over
two pi to the t by two
psi one half
exponent
minus one half
x i minus mu minus
l z i
times psi inverse
x i minus mu
l mu minus
l z i
right and here if if you
if you ah if you basically
you know just take the derivatives set
it equal to 0
in order to do that however there is
this expectation over here
right so we have this expectation over
this whole thing
so in order to take the expectation we
will now have to
break this into smaller chunks so this
will be
log of
log of 1 over 2 pi to the d by 2
and this will be minus half
log determinant of psi
log in the exponent will cancel minus
one half
x minus mu minus l
z i psi inverse
x minus mu minus l e i
right
so you still have the i equals one to n
expectation
z i from q i
right and now we can we can
ah we can see what terms depend on z and
what do not
we are taking an arc max of an
expectation of something
right and so this term
does not have z nor does it have
any of the parameters so this can just
cancel out
right this term does not have z so
it can come out of the expectation
this term does have z and in in order to
perform the expectation you will have to
expand out
you know distribute this multiplication
across all terms
and once we once we once we do all that
and you take the gradients and set it
equal to 0 we will get
l is equal to sum over
i equals one to n
x i minus mu
times mu z given x
transpose where mu z given x transpose
was from the posterior
right it is that big expression over
here
times
summation i equals one to n
mu z given x
mu z given x transpose
again this this mu z given x is the full
posterior that we derived earlier
plus sigma
given x right
so this is the m step update for
l and similarly the m step update for mu
will be 1 over n
i equals 1 to n
x i right this should be pretty straight
forward because we assumed
we we gave z a 0 mean and x
you know x therefore had to be ah so mu
therefore had to have
this this mean and then
we calculate this phi matrix
1 over n i equals 1 to n
oh boy this is painful x i
x i transpose minus
x i mu z
given x transpose
l transpose minus l
mu z given x
x i transpose plus
l
i am getting tired writing this mu z
given x
mu z given x transpose
plus sigma c given
x times l transpose
and psi i i
equal to v i i
right so this is an intermediate
computation and you take the diagonal
values of this
and set them equal to be psi
iii right so there's this
a lot of symbols a lot of monstrous
looking expressions
i would not expect you to memorize this
right
however the the larger story from this
is the way we went about applying em
the the recipe of applying m we
we obtained the you know we derived the
the e step
um as as the simple posterior and in the
m step
we had to take this expectation with
respect to z
of of the the uh of the of the elbow
uh so the elbow which is the expectation
uh with respect to z
a crucial point uh to note here
is that in many places if you if you you
know search for
em algorithm on on google and try to
learn about em
algorithm in many places
you might see an algorithm that is
described like this where in the e step
you know calculate expectation of z
and in the m step
you know do arc max
of p of z comma expectation of z
right you might see many many uh
articles or documents
that describe east up this way where e
step corresponds to the expectation
m step corresponds to maximization
this recipe this this this uh
sequence of steps is true only sometimes
right in simple models you can write it
like this in gaussian mixture models you
can write it like this
right but the the correct way to do
expectation maximization
is to have in the e step perform
only calculation of the posterior and
construction of the elbow
and in the m step maximize the elbow in
simple models
those two steps are equivalent to this
but
if you were to do this for more complex
models
it will be wrong if you follow this step
for
factor analysis you will get it wrong it
works only for simple steps
but the the the process that works for
any model
is in e-step construct the posterior q
the the q distribution and in the m step
maximize the elbow that works all the
time no matter what
for simple models that is equivalent to
this but you know that's something to
to uh uh keep in your mind
all right with that we'll uh we'll break
if you have any questions you know come
up
to the stage and we can we can